they slither
yes
[Music]
especially when you catch them
[Music]
sometimes raining snakes is more art
than science
the whole of the snake is the stakes are
high
you can make it difficult time to talk
about that there's enough Venom there to
kill more than 100 Papua New guineans
get ready to go hand to scale and face
to fan with some of the world's
deadliest cold-blooded killers
[Music]
first on the list
the Australian copperhead
[Music]
this is an Aussie Super Snake
a muscular serpent with a lethal bite
[Music]
the copperhead goes where other snakes
fear to slither
scales snowing mountains
swim through swamps and hunt in freezing
temperatures
but survival in this harsh environment
comes with a price
there isn't much on the menu
[Music]
except other copperheads
this snake is a cannibal and it's being
stalked by a master
Brian Bush lives for reptiles he has a
shed full of poison let me introduce you
to some of my friends
his own custom tools this is a quick
release frame
makes it really easy
plenty of attitude all right
he even looks like a reptile talk about
a freak of nature
all we're going to remember is snake's
an important part of the environment
brain uses his poisonous prizes for
education
but there's one kind of snake Behavior
even this Venom virtuoso has never
witnessed
cannibalism
snakes do eat other snakes as a bonus
when going after the same meal or
different species as prey
but there's one Australian species that
consistently swallows its own kind
and that's the copperhead
Ryan has come to the Misty Mountains of
Tasmania to observe this anti-social
snake Behavior
but the Copperheads aren't exactly
cooperating
a little snipe and come ahead
get ready
sometimes even a master gets cool I was
expecting the snake to go over the bank
they did a u-turn and crew straight into
this Muddy Creek here to lay under the
water for an hour but I'm going to keep
looking
with no snakes in sight Brian resorts to
some unconventional methods
maybe the dance has worked
[Music]
I'm interested in the cannibalism in
this snake so I'm going to Chuck it in a
bag and take it with me for a little
experiment I've got planned
now it's time for a little dietary test
local herpetologist Bill flowers has a
frozen surprise planned for this
cold-blooded cannibal
okay Bill's helping us out with this
experiment he picked up a couple of road
kill Copperhead Road killed no worries
pretty poisonous popsicle
we can actually wait for this to throw
it out a bit
Bill and Brian build an enclosure for
the snakes that simulates their natural
habitat yeah sure thought out let's go
don't worry all they have to do is add
the copperhead roadkill and they'll be
ready to go
they've even figured out a way to bring
a dead snake back to life we're supposed
to manipulate the dead Copperhead with a
bit of wire move it along we'll have its
head up it should look real and see how
that works straight into my eyes hello
Brian what are you doing in Tassie I'm
chasing blokes like you I'm after
hopperheads
it's now or never
this is the most likely one to eat it
but it's carrying a fair bit of
condition look how mad
the roadkill puppet definitely catches
the live snake's attention
[Music]
and Brian learns that this lethal surge
is more interested in biting its
Brothers than people
swallow it plus there's nothing like a
bit of cannibalism to work up an
appetite
[Music]
it did it it worked yes
[Music]
bill now I better buy your steak I
reckon well that did make me hungry mate
let's go
[Music]
slender snake hunts in a more unusual
element
the air
meet the paradise tree snake a reptile
that's more jumped than bite
when danger threatens or food beckons it
flattens its frame and takes the plunge
turning its entire body into a
serpentine glider
[Music]
Jake Socha has come to Singapore to
catch a few of these Airborne acrobats
these animal biomechanics and he aims to
find out how these reptiles defy gravity
can you have an animal that's shaped
like a cylinder that's able to move
through the air I'm just fascinated with
how it works
I want you guys to be ringed around here
so I want a couple people outside too
I think on the ground
try grabbing one that can fly
how many gaps up here you're not gonna
come out to yourself then straight up
straight up from your head you got a
Norman you got him he's right above you
come on that good a move needs some
instant replay
[Music]
fortunately practice eventually makes
perfect all right and luckily a bite
from this snake isn't dangerous to
humans beautiful snake isn't it that was
literally a catch you guys check now
comes the real reason for the wrangling
[Music]
film The Snake fly all you need are two
towering scaffolds some rope a Fearless
cameraman and a love of heights
or not I don't like heights thankfully
they've they've stopped at a
it's not it shouldn't be
too wobbly up there
that's the idea
a non-toxic paint job will help a
computer program track the snake's
movements during flight
it's show time
a little wobbly there yeah this is what
keeps me from uh
plummeting to the Earth
I hope okay I'm reaching down for the
snake
I don't normally name my snakes but one
of my volunteers here name this one air
Tony
you'll see what Tony can do here no one
will force the snake to fly it's looking
down it's going now
takes the leap all on its own
[Music]
again
again
that this is fantastic
and they don't seem to mind a few crash
landed
[Applause]
if they can make a break for it
[Music]
finally Jake has his footage
close-up real-time view of a servant in
flight
this footage is going to help me at
least get some hints at what's going on
in a detailed sense
so watch out Travelers the next great
airplane design just might have a little
reptile in it
this monster would never even get off
the ground
the Gaboon viper six and a half feet
long and weighing up to 18 pounds this
beefy serpent is the largest Viper on
the planet
with the world's longest fangs
these massive two inch long needles can
inject more Venom than any other snake
enough to Kill 30 humans with a single
bite
in any Fang off this lethal Behemoth is
the odds on favorite
but once snake wrangler is eager to take
him on
[Music]
Dr Sultan Takis has searched for snakes
through jungles deserts and oceans in
134 countries
Gathering Venom and DNA samples for his
research into snake digestion
the deadlier the better
I'm also very fascinated by venomous and
poisonous animals I don't think I'm
crazy because so far I managed to be
alive the guy is herpetology's Indiana
Jones minus the snake phobia
though this snake Maniac does have one
problem
he's allergic to Anti-Venom
so I have to really be careful allergic
reaction can kill me
so a Fang off with the world's largest
Viper could end very badly
but first Zoltan has to find one
he heads deep into cameroon's remote but
biki National Park
Guided by local Baka pygmies
[Music]
in here there are plenty of places for a
snake to hide
[Music]
what are we looking for Shades of bran
the goblin Viper hiding in the leaf
leader extremely hard to notice in the
forest floor
on day six the Baca guides spot the
prize
one of them just told me he found a big
Viper near the river
so excited I realized I really want to
see
anybody sees the snake right now yes
those guys would actually sing this next
one
to the safe
well camouflaged monster
the Gaboon viper the king of all vipers
great
everybody's just stamped me don't move
yeah okay
an adult Gaboon viper has virtually no
natural enemies
and can bring down prey as big as an
antelope
one wrong move can be failed
at 11 pounds the resultan has just
bagged a big hunk of snake okay
foreign
gets a good look at what those massive
fangs can do
and plenty of venom for his research
[Music]
days later the team catches an even
bigger one
it is the hugest Goblin Viper I ever
seen a six and a half foot eighteen
pound Leviathan hiding in plain sight
we've watched ahead of the snake it's
really The Catch of the whole Expedition
great
[Music]
Zoltan has what he came for
this is why I came to Africa tissue
samples from 44 snakes including the
goblin Viper and the rhinoceros Walker
and these samples are just the first of
many
this snake-loving Superstar already has
his next capture in sight
[Music]
no one wants a venomous snake for a
neighbor
especially if it's as lethal as the cape
cobra
one of the most dangerous culture
species in Africa
a bite from this hooded serpent can kill
a man in 30 minutes
fortunately In the Heat of the day this
snake gets a taste for Real Estate
I've got a cobra in the house well if
you live in Cape Town South Africa you
know who to call
the snake Buster
speaking you left the message away for
Sean Thomas facing some of the world's
deadliest fangs is just part of a day's
work very pretty
that's
unnecessary Behavior you see this Cobra
is dangerous
you can kill all of us here you can kill
10 people this guy
it's gonna be a busy day let's go
Sean doesn't always face the Invaders
solo
like any successful business owner he
has employees
this one will work for food
in some cases there'll be snakes that we
can't find inside the house and to learn
the meerkat plays a very helpful role in
actually locating that snake his senses
are very very sharp
I believe you got a snake in the house
[Music]
meerkats are natural snake hunters in
the wild and in the living room
[Music]
where's the snake
[Music]
timin has another valuable skill
he's a thousand times more immune to
snake venom than Sean
a match made in snake Buster heaven
and it doesn't take long before he
delivers the goods
okay he seems to be paying a lot of
attention to under this cut so I'm gonna
take him away and see what's underneath
his couch
dust bunnies of the most dangerous kind
oh great it's a beautiful Cape Cobra and
uh
not the ideal specimen to have in your
home
so if you see any more of those ones
you're gonna call me Sean will release
the snakes into the wild be careful or
into his basement
my snake room is um a sealed lockable
room underneath my house I keep Forest
cobras Cape cobras puff headers
burgetters an extreme case of not
leaving your work at the office
[Music]
want Venom well there's only one way to
get it gotcha stock grab and milk an
angry snake
that means going up against some of the
snake world's most lethal Superstars
Taipan then bring it back quick and this
is one of the worst
the papuan taipan
one of the most venomous snakes in the
world
when threatened this 10-foot long Terror
comes out fighting
collecting multiple fights filled with
toxic venom
without treatment more than 80 percent
of bite victims die
this pillow out
and Australian herpetologist David
Williams is holding one in his hands
like a pet
this town is Ground Zero for Venom
victims
moragina in Papua New Guinea in this
place snake is another word for death
moragina has one of the highest
mortality rates of snake bite in the
world the wife from The Veranda it is a
very fast snakes and if they get in
among people right they'll bite everyone
inside
for those patients fortunate enough to
get to Port Moresby the only anti-venom
for this deadly reptile costs a fortune
and it has to be refrigerated
but refrigerators and cash are in short
supply here
can't help but really feel you know
heartbroken having to Stand By and Watch
a family see a loved one die under those
circumstances
so we actually got a fair bit of venom
out of this space David wants to develop
a freeze-dried anti-venom to save lives
in remote areas
but the crucial cure has a main
ingredient
live Taipan Venom
that means a snake hunt
his only defensive weapons
a stick a bag and his wits so you guys
saw a snake here this morning huh all
right we're about to Aussie can you show
me
[Music]
Taipan
okay clear clear now get back out of the
road
[Applause]
[Music]
snakes don't just strike by land
they also stalked the Seas
and all snakes can swim
but the banded sea crate is an
underwater champion
specially adapted tail turns his entire
body into a paddle
large lungs enable it to stand or water
for up to eight hours
and nature didn't skimp on the poison
the crates Venom is 10 times more potent
than a rattlesnakes
is back in search of that poison
hey excellent here is the price his new
goal to solve a reptilian Mystery House
snakes can be immune to their own toxic
venom
first stop the Pacific island countries
of Vanuatu and Fiji
where land and ocean teams with sea
snakes
to get enough samples Zoltan needs to
catch at least 20 swimming serpents
and when night falls the snakes seem
eager to volunteer
very very nice the secret
this snake just came out from the water
just came out from there nowhere oh
there is another one the small one it's
great
the island is crawling with trains
excellent this is getting really busy
tonight
it's Rush Hour Russia here in Vanuatu so
nice
two back two back full of C6 great
back on land it's time to harvest
something
good morning neighbors but the crates
have other ideas hopefully okay too much
traffic here
[Music]
it's going back
there's catching snakes and then there's
keeping them
okay we're not gonna lose one single
thing
[Music]
the jailbreak thwarted his old time gets
what he came for blood and poison
[Music]
aren't his only Target
Bandits see crate Venom is similar to
COBRA Venom otherwise known as
snakesville
and this monster can spew poisonous
saliva with the best
[Music]
the spinning cobra has its cousin's
Telltale hood and fierce looking fangs
foreign but it also lives up to its name
when confronted this aggressive Cobra
can spit toxic venom straight into a
predator's eyes from over eight feet
away
causing blindness
or worse
and if the spit Doesn't Kill You its
bite will
like the sea crate the Cobra is immune
to its own toxins
unfortunately this old time
he's left the Tranquil Waters of the
Pacific for the rain forests of Tanzania
to face off with this formidable foe
snake except he's not about to expose
his face
corralling a spitter requires some
special armor
the musk is absolutely important goggle
is covering only the eyes are not enough
because you don't want to get venom spat
on your face
it's Venom's viewing serpent has no
interest in being a part of the
scientific process
there is no room for error here if you
do a smaller work you can die
foreign
he's still dangerous
blood sample secure it's time to change
from snake superhero the science
professor
if he unlocks the key to Venom immunity
his discoveries could lead to better
anti-venoms or disease-busting drugs
[Music]
this lethal Bruiser may also be able to
help with some discoveries
Australia's Death Adder
three feet long with a small rat-like
tail used to lure prey
the Death Adder has a lightning fast
strike
one bite from the snake can kill
it likes to stand its ground in a fight
foreign
[Music]
for Craig and Jackie Adams Mar till
death do us part could be sooner than
later we later venomous life and you
want to keep leading it you've got to
know what you're doing
good stuff
they both work at the Australian reptile
Park north of Sydney
a wildlife sanctuary and vital source of
Venom used to produce Australia's ant
event
[Music]
the reptile Dairy that produces poison
and it's Craig and Jackie's Job to catch
new milkers
so they're off on a cattle call for
death adders
but even in snake countries finding live
ones isn't going to be easy
I don't think we're going to be able to
use them
all right catch us later look after
those adders
so the happy couple decides to go all
out
hi
come here
look at this beauty Jackie is ready to
bag her hidden treasure
now Jack just be careful mate she might
be moving slow but when she wants to
move 0.25 of a second should be on you
before you can blink
[Music]
nice stuff nice nice stuff right
but one Adder isn't enough for a Venom
form and the next one they find isn't
too interested in joining the Harvest
you're gonna have to dig it out there's
no way you're putting your hand in there
Aussie snake
were like to grab their prize by the
tail
that won't work with a Death Adder this
serpent uses its tail as a lure and it's
good at striking from behind
don't do anything stupid cry let's try
again
big
go in front
go all right all right
that was that was lucky mate
really lucky promise me you will never
ever put your hand in one of those
crevices all right adjust the Heat of
the Moment that's all
I just thought you know tiger snake
something like that I can just go bammo
and you got it out
Jackie needs Craig to stick around I
can't wait to show any especially when
they get their milkers back to the corn
[Music]
I'm usually these guys are pretty
comfortable without fighting the bowl
see the fangs there they're just long
fangs on their feathers
they're big fangs that will save lives
[Music]
not all snakes are aggressive even if
they pack a poisonous punch
North America's pit bikers have a
fearsome reputation
they get their name from these small
heat pits below the eyes
which can detect body heat
even in total darkness
and these three are the worst
cottonmouth also known as the water
moccasin
a semi-aquatic snake armed with deadly
venom that can melt muscle
the Eastern Diamondback Rattlesnake it
may use its famous Tail as a warning but
this bad boy can strike it one third of
its body length
and the copperhead one of America's most
common venomous snakes
this Viper is responsible for a quarter
of venomous snake bites in the U.S
but is this poison Posse really that
ferocious
herpetologist Jesus Rivas isn't so sure
snakes have the bad reputation in The
Lord of many cultures
vicious as malignant as evil and one of
the things that I want to know is what
is the real nature of the behavior of
pit Pipers hey how are you this is his
first stop a snake infested South
Carolina swamp with colleague Rick
Gibbons
this is like a great plate for snake
isn't it
it's the perfect habitat for
cottonmouths and it doesn't take long to
find one
big one now it's a good looking they're
all good looking
but the snake doesn't seem eager to
attack be his first response did you see
that escape
even when it's stepped on
stage got his mouth open but he's not
biting snake opens the mouth and reaches
to his food by dropping by just punches
with his mouth open doesn't even try
that's right
20012
they need those fangs to eat not to bite
people it's a threat display I could
hurt you leave me alone
it looks like this cottonmouth is all
show and no strike
that may not be the case with a
rattlesnake
Eastern Diamondback can inject five
times more Venom than the cottonmouth
so in Florida Dr Bruce means tracks his
subjects by radio transmitter to avoid
stepping on them
hey Jesus
oh cool
oh what a beauty big guy look at that
and you don't want to ever be bitten by
this snake the Eastern Diamondback in my
opinion is the most dangerous snake in
the United States in Canada when you get
bitten by the snake it's deadly serious
yet even this Bruiser hesitates to
strike
he could reach you yet he's not he's
like a boxer jabbing keeping the
distance showing if he's Rich showing
where he can do her but not really
aiming to hurt him clearly these pit
vipers are more passive and aggressive
[Music]
and this amateur snake wrangler is
willing to take that on faith might be
something
in the tiny Appalachian town of Edwina
Tennessee Church Pastor Jimmy Morrow
likes to search for deadly Copperhead
conduits right here is the is one of the
nicest Pikes it's our band toast that's
our top right here you go
he has a reason for catching copperheads
on Sundays he takes them to church
where they star in a pretty unusual
sermon amen
hallelujah in The Book of Mark in the
Bible's New Testament Jesus told his
followers that those who believe in him
could handle serpent and no harm would
come to them
[Applause]
these Believers take that literally
he's moving them around in a manner that
will strongly discourage anybody to do
unbelievable and it seems like their
prayers are answered there are no fights
[Applause]
is it a reptilian miracle
pure dumb luck or a box of defanged pets
now this is a copperhead he's a benefit
from snag and and he was caught
okay out of the wall right okay now
watch it okay so same buying it see
y'all like poison just like its cousins
The Fearsome Copperhead is more of a
lover than a fighter
or maybe they just behave in church
every year around 100 000 people lose
their lives to snake bites worldwide
and the spectacled Cobra is one of the
world's leading killers
snake Charmers have made this snake face
but the Cobra's real talents are speed
agility and a potent bite
but there's another reason why this
snake is so dangerous
it likes to live near people and when
human and snake meet the snake often
wins
unless you're a professional snake
wrangler
the arula people of Southern India have
been hunting deadly serpents for
Generations
it's a risky profession
India has the highest rate of snake bite
deaths in the world
consider the URL of the best snake
catches because they're the people who
read the sign that the snakes have left
behind and find out exactly where
they've gone
pitologist Rob Whitaker has worked to be
a Rula for years
this is a cobra scat and I'm afraid I
wouldn't be able to identify frankly I'm
just sort of learning the ropes even
though it's been 25 years since I
started working with them
foreign
Hunters survived by selling snake skins
if they lived long enough to kill their
Quarry
[Music]
today India's venomous snakes are
protected so the arula have gone from
Hunters to Farmers with a rather unusual
Harvest
toxic venom
[Music]
the arula snake Farms provide over 80
percent of Venom used for anti-venom in
India
and if they're bitten there won't be any
Hazard pay
[Music]
learned snake tracking from his father
and on a cobra hunt generations of
know-how quickly pay off
yeah look at that
two cobras inside I mean that's
too bad
even faced with two spectacled cobras
the arula hunter shows no fear
[Music]
but maybe he should
leave
a very quick bite on his leg we're
hoping it's okay but
okay we just walk slow and easy and get
up there
Kali has to move slowly to stop the
spread of venom
he's in a Race Against Time
the symptoms can start to show within
minutes
yeah
and the nearest hospital is hours away
it wasn't a very big Cobra but on the
other hand the Cobra that size has
enough Venom to kill three or four
people the worst case scenario is if he
did get a very high dose of Venom he
could actually go into respiratory
paralysis within a couple of hours
right yeah he's like a snake catcher
collie's breathing grows worse doctors
decide to administer antibetan
made from the Cobra Venom is people risk
their lives to harvest
kali's job almost killed him
but the arula's long tradition of snake
wrangling will continue to save lives
not all of these cold-blooded killers
are deadly to humans
but even a boa constrictor can put up a
fight
long smooth and full of muscle the boa
isn't poisonous but it's definitely a
brute
boas don't strike they bite Embrace and
squeeze
suffocating their prey
boas may not pack poison but they have
plenty of teeth
so when it comes to a Fang off
herpetology grad student Scott fob check
still has to take extra care
got a female
12 centimeters for the tail he's in
Belize to research the size and
evolution of boa constrictors
[Music]
three four 106. Scott is trying to find
out why Island Bowers are so much
smaller than Mainland boas
we have snakes on the islands that are
completely different in size male and
snakes are at least twice as long and
four or five times as heavy
let's get some boas
on the island the trees are dripping
with snakes
so we got one right up in this tree
right here looks like it's choosing an
ambush position right at the end of this
dead branch
[Music]
unfortunately Scott is the one who gets
ambushed
[Music]
you've never said that Island snakes are
docile they'll take a bite out of you
he's got you lose the feeling in my hand
now Scott meets Mainland females
but These Girls Aren't into pristine
jungles
Belize City's Boas have a more urban
hunted round this is not for the week's
direct the town dump isn't classic in
stricter habitat
but the swampy garbage is home to a
snake's Smorgasbord it's a Haven for
other animals like rats and and other
prey items that the boers are going to
eat
want to be a snake wrangler roll up your
sleeves and dive in
this is fun stuff
you know you're just like
in the right spot to find a dead body
just lying right around here right in
this car window just like his head's
sticking out
meanwhile
comes to the bow as Scott already has
problems are just the beginning
[Applause]
after all the driving his biggest charge
is a little carsick that was a big
lizard which means some big praise
coming up the other way
the road was a little bit too much for
and then an island Bowen disappears into
things I can't find a snake
this is not what I wanted to do oh God
and I think that the snake sneaked down
the back of the sink
yeah he's in there
one hotel sink 179 dollars huh the boa
priceless
some snakes like to set their sights
High
especially the eyelash viper
the elongated scales over its eyes give
it one of the prettiest faces in the
serpent world
but don't be fooled by its flirty gaze
this petite Hunter is armed with long
needle-like fangs that can deliver a
Venom packing puncture in less than a
quarter of a second
foreign
vipers like to climb trees
so this snake wrangler is taking the
Fang off to new and dizzying Heights
they usually works out for honestly but
not always when it comes to researching
reptiles Viper specialist Jeff Soro
likes it Wild and Woolly
from the mud
seize to the shrubs there you go good
job to the trees it's even earned him a
nickname
jungle Jeff to me I've found some sort
of means of justifying doing what many
would call childish behavior he's come
to the jungles of Panama in search of
vipers with eyelashes and he wants to
prove a new Theory
yeah this is what we're really looking
for according to Conventional research
these pretty Killers pounce on prey at
night
but jungle Jeff isn't known for being
conventional
he believes that the eyelash viper also
hunts during the day
and he's going to make them cough up the
prey to prove it
he had a big meal so the procedure of
calping snakes is is pretty standard and
at a certain point once the spray item
gets near the head they sort of
regurgitate on their own bro
all right now whoa It's a frog
a lot of the prey items that we've found
in these snakes are animals that are
active during the day to prove these
snakes are diurnal Jeff needs to see a
daytime viper strike for himself
and that means pulling out all the stops
to catch one
[Music]
that's always a nice sound when you're
about to climb up in a tree
[Music]
going good
Wrangler defines the phrase survival of
the fittest
vipers 27 meters of trees so I figure
that's
that's a good enough reason for me to
climb
see exactly how high these little guys
will go
Jeff can spot an eyelash viper more than
100 feet up
I mean it's hard to believe that the
snake is holding itself on the ball of
this tree with that little flake apart
bring it back down
we just try to drop the snake right and
that's the plan
[Music]
we're in the bag
works that's fine
[Music]
with their scaly study subject at a
lower altitude
it's time for a little afternoon snack
who's it they eat during the day huh
yeah I guess so wow Jeff survives his
fang off
but this little lizard isn't so lucky
the first try very first time I mean I
know we got it but you know but it was
it doesn't take long to prove Jeff's
Theory
it seems that day or night no snake will
turn down a free lunch
they'll even swallow it whole
[Music]
gotcha from Savannah's to swamps this is
not for the week's direct Under the Sea
the tops of the trees
these snake experts know how to face off
with fangs and survive they take great
risks
for great rewards
and that's a Fang off even a snake can
get behind
[Music]
[Music]